PROFESSOR: The law
of total expectation
will give us another
important tool for reasoning
about expectations.
And it's basically a rule like
the law of total probability,
closely related to it
really, for reasoning
by cases about expectation.
So it requires a
definition of what's
called conditional expectation.
So the expectation of a random
variable R, given event A,
is simply what you
get by thinking
of replacing the
probability that R equals v
by the probability that
R equals v given A.
So it's the sum over
all the possible values
that R might take
of the probability
that R takes that
value, given A.
OK, with that definition,
we can state the basic form
of the law of total
expectation, which
says if you want to calculate
the expectation of R,
you can split it into
cases, according to whether
or not A occurs.
It's simply the
conditional expectation
of R given A times
the probability of A,
plus the conditional expectation
of R, given not A times
the probability of
not A. So it really
looks [? as ?] the
same format as the law
of total probability.
Now, of course it
generalizes to many cases.
So the general form
would say that I
can calculate the
expectation of R
by breaking it up into
the case that A 1 holds
times the probability of A
1, the case that A 2 holds
times the probability
of A 2, through A n.
And this could very
well, and typically is,
an infinite sum, where
the [? A i's ?] of course,
are a partition of
the sample space--
so they're all the different
cases, either A 1 or A 2
or A 3, they're disjoint.
And altogether, they cover the
entire set of possibilities.
Well, let's use this to get
a nice different and simpler
way-- more elementary way-- of
calculating the expected number
of heads and flips.
So let's let of n be the
expected number of heads
and flips-- just shorthand,
because the notational
will be easier to
work with than writing
capital E brackets of H n.
So what do we know
about expectation of n?
Well, I can express it in
terms of the expectation
of the remaining flips.
So if I have n flips to
perform, they're independent.
Then if I perform the first
flip, something happens.
And after that I'm
going to do n more
flips, and the expected
number of flips
is going to be the expected
number on the remaining n
minus 1 plus what happened now.
Well, if I flipped a head
first, then I've got a 1
as adding to my total
number of heads.
And then I'm going
to do n more flips,
so the expected
number of flips is
going to be that 1
plus the expected
number on the rest of them.
If the first flip was not
a head, it was a tail,
then the total expected
number of heads
is simply the expected number of
heads on the rest of the flips.
And these are two cases where
I can apply total expectation.
So by total expectation, the
expected number in n flips
is 1 plus e n minus 1 times
the probability of a head,
plus e n minus 1 times
the probability of a tail.
Well, now we could do a little
algebra multiply through here
by p-- that becomes a p,
and this becomes a p times
e n and minus 1.
So I've got e n minus 1 times
p, and e n minus 1 times
q-- remembering that p plus q
is 1, this simplifies to being
simply e n minus 1 plus p.
Well, this is a very simple kind
of recursive definition of e n,
because you can see
what's going to happen.
Subtracting 1 from n adds a p.
So if I subtract 2 from n,
I add another p-- I get 2 p.
And continuing all
the way to the end,
by the time I get to 0,
I've gotten n times p.
And I've just figured out what
I was familiar with already--
which we previously
derived by differentiating
the binomial theorem-- the
expected number of heads
in n flips is n times p.
But this time I got it in a
somewhat more elementary way,
by appealing to
total expectation.